안녕하세요 시도입니다 오늘은 제가
좋아하는 브랜드를 하나 소개하려
합니다 오늘 소개할 브랜드는 제
마음에 여러 방이 있지만 그중 가장
큰 방 하나에 자리하고 있는 타이가
타카 아입니다 타이가 타카시는 동명의
디자이너가 2018년 시작한 미국
베이스의 일본 브랜드예요 제가 타이가
타카시를 처음 알게 된 건 3년
쯤인데 에센스에서 모르는 브랜드를 막
클릭해 보다가 찾게 됐어요 말 많은
브랜드에서 내낸 복각 스타일인데
뭔가이 브랜드만의 특별하고 좋은
의미로 변태 같은 구석이
느껴졌어요 공에도 들어가 보고
그러다가 어느 순간부터 나는이
브랜드를 꼭 직접 봐야겠다
생각했습니다 그런데 그 당시에
찾아보니까 국내에서 제대로 바잉하는
곳이 없는 거예요 그래서 일본에 직접
갔습니다 2022년 12월 저는
드디어 타이가 타카시를 처음으로
경험했습니다
타이가 타카시 매장은 일본에도 몇
군데 였고 교토에 유일하게 플래그십
매장이 있어요 현재까지도 타이가
타카시의 단독 매장은 교토가
유일합니다 당시에 제가 교토에
방문했을 땐 매장 한켠에서 전시가
열리고 있었는데요 전시 제목은
23ss 시즌 컬렉션의 제목이기도
했던 the ofs 의역하면 그가
떠난 자리에서 정도가 될 것
같습니다 디자이너 타타카 2022년
4월 9일에 27살이라는 어린 나이로
세상을
떠났습니다이 전신은 그가 떠난 후
처음 진행된 컬렉션을 소개하면서 그를
추모하는 자리기도 했는데요 타이가
타카시는 본인을 고고 학자라 부르기도
했는데 브랜드의 전시를 가보거나 좀만
찾아보면 그럴 만도 해요 제가 좀
있다 그건 다시
설명드리겠습니다 저는 타이가 타카시의
팝업이나 전신은 총 세 차례 갔어요
교토 서울숲 그리고 근 해방까지
전시나 팝업에 가면 되게 다양한 걸
주는데요 일단 대부분의 공간에서 저는
엽서를 받았어요 전실을 찍은 사진도
있고 제품 사진도 있고 제품을
제조하는 과정을 담은 사진도 있고
되게 다양합니다 타이가 타카시의
마케팅의 장점 중 하나는 소비자를
굉장히 잘 조련 한다는 점인 것
같아요 단순히 우리 바지 되게 예뻐
우리 할인도 해 이런 직관적인 말들이
아니라 전시에서 나눠 주는 것들을
보면 우리가 추구하는 바는 이런 거야
그리고 이걸 우리의 제품들에 담았어
관심 있으면 한번 봐 봐라는 식으로
은근히 설득을 잘합니다 물론 저도
설득된 사람 중
하나고요 보여 드리고 있는 건 작년
서울숲 코사이어티 팝업에서 나눠준
전시도 그래요 타이가 타카시가 생전에
엄청난 수집광이었다고 합니다 전시장
중앙에 타이가 타카시가 아카이빙한
물건들이 있었는데 1900년 초반
기모노와 가죽 소재들 엄청 오래된
책들까지 있었어요 솔직히 보면서 이런
것까지 모아야 하나라는 생각이 삐져
나오긴 했었는데 아무튼 다 이브랜드의
피가 되고 살이 된 아카이브가 아닐까
합니다 또 보여 드리는 건 전시에서
받은 피우는 향이에요 아까워서 하나도
쓴 적은 없는데 타이가 타카시가 옷
외에도 중요시하는 것들이 많아요이
향이 될 수도 있고 팝업에서 최소 두
차례는 보여준 다도 또한 그렇고요
저는 이런 옷이 아닌 주변 요소들이
모여서 타이가 타카라 브랜드를
완성시켰다고
생각합니다 그럼 이제 제가 구매한
순서대로 갖고 있는 타이가 타카시의
제품들을 좀 소개해
보겠습니다 첫 번째는 교토에 갔을 때
구매한 타이가 타카시의 509 Arc
가디건입니다이 제품을 구매한다는 세
가지 이유가 있어요 첫째로 처음 보는
브랜드인데 다 좀 비싸서 아우터는 못
사겠다고 둘째로 올해 입을 수 있는
걸 사자 생각했습니다 마지막으로
당시에 제가 라운드넥 가디건에 꽂혀
있었어요 그때는 남성 욕 라운드넥이
많이 안 나왔었어요 그런데 마침
가격을 보고 혼란에 빠진 와중에
가디건이 있어서 이거라도 구매했습니다
물론 얘도 저렴하진
않았어요이 제품의 Arc n 아메리칸
레드 크로스의 약자인데요 2차
세계대전 당시 미국 적십자에서 만들던
가디건을 복각해 만든 제품이라 이런
이름을 붙였다고 합니다 복각 모델이긴
하지만 본레 모델과 차이점도 분명히
있는데요 본래 미국 적십자 니트는
단추가 없는 프로보 방식인데 타이가
타카시 제품은 편하게 입기 위해서
전면에 단추를 더했다고 합니다 단추가
있는 세로 선의 텍스처가 좀 다른데
이것 때문에 그 할머니 할아버지들이
입으시는 가디건처럼 보이긴 합니다
그래서 구매할 때 고민했어요 블랙과
베이지 두 색상 중에 뭘 사야 할까
저라면 웬만해서는 블랙을 구매하겠지만
그래도 제품의 핵심 디테일이 잘
보이는게 좋을 것 같아서 이걸로
구매했습니다 지금은 살짝
후회합니다 좀 아쉬운 건 사이즈가
작아요 지금은 좀 늘어나서 그나마
나왔는데 처음에는 팔이 정말 해봤어요
아무래도 원 제품의 사이즈감을 반영한
듯한데 요즘 타이가 타카시 제품들은
피드백이 있었는지 상의들이 좀
예전보다는 여유롭게 나오기도
합니다 바로 바지로 넘어가 볼게요
제가 입고 있는 건 타이가 타카
시에서 캐리 오버로 나오는 704
데님 팬츠입니다 일자 와이드 피로
어디든 붙이기 좋아서 가장 많이 입는
바지 중 하나인데요 작년 말에 서울숲
팝업때 구매했습니다 이품 도 역시나
복각 있데 재미난 건 흔히들 하는
빈티지 리바이스 복각이 아니라는
점인데요 타이가 타카시는 리바이스
같은 큰 브랜드보다 작은 매장들에
있는 브랜드를 선호했다고 합니다이
제품은 리바이스가 아닌 1920년대
JC 페니 매장의 포모스트 아는
브랜드의 모델을 복각해서 만들었는데요
후면 신치백이 서스펜더 용 단추 같은
고증이 매력 있는 바입니다 이제 보여
드릴 제품은 타이가 타카시의 70
데님 자켓입니다 바지만 사서 입고
다니다가 결국 몇 달 있다가 셋업으로
있는 데님 자켓도
구매했습니다 계속 나오는이 번호가
궁금하실 수 있는데 이건 타이가
타카시의 모델 분류 번호인데 뭐 예를
들어서 7 7로 시작하는 제품들은
전부 대님 제품 그리고 번호가 5로
시작하면 니트류 이런 식입니다 이런
분류의 형태도 뭔가 타이가 타카 씨가
본인을 역사 학자라 칭하는 것과
가다와 있는 듯합니다
이 자켓은 한남동의 맥클레즈
구매했습니다 바지와 마찬가지로
포모스트 브랜드의 모델을 복각했어
이게 입는 사람만 아는 거긴 하지만
자켓이랑 바지가 조금 워싱 차이가
있어요 제가 바지를 더 먼저
구매하기도 했고 더 자주 입다 보니까
바지의 물이 좀 더
빠졌습니다 자켓은 목에 닿는 안쪽에
바지는 바지 뒤편 허리춤에 타이가
타카시의 상징인 가죽 패치가 있습니다
이 가죽 패치는 머드 다잉을 해서
만들었는데요이 머드 다잉을 일본의
아마미오 섬의 장인이
진행했는데이 섬에서 머드 다잉을 하는
다른 브랜드로는 잘 아시는 비즈 빔이
있습니다이 대님 상하이는 운지로 얇은
축에 속하는데요 그래서 가령 페스의
논워시 데님 제품들을 입었을 때
느껴지는 갑옷 같은 느낌은 전혀
없어요이 사이즈감을 설명하면 상위는
적당히 여유로운데 지에 비하면
상대적으로 딱 맞는 느낌이긴 합니다
다행히 제가 상이는 너무 오버하지
않게 그리고 하이는 여유롭게 입는 걸
좋아하다 보니까 제 취향과 잘 맞아
떨어집니다 제가 사실이 입고 있는
대님 팬츠랑 똑같은 모델을 하나 더
구매했습니다 똑같이 704 모델인데
제가 추가로 구매한 건 워시드
버전이에요이 바지는 사실 제가 교토에
갔을 때 처음 봤었어요 옷 보고 이런
말 하는게 너무 이상한 사람 같긴
하지만
진짜 첫눈에 보고 반했습니다 그 당시
물어봤을 때는 이게 비매 품이 그런데
이게 얼마 전에 이사 시즌에 출시된
거예요 공에서 바로
구매했습니다이 바지는 제가 가진
청바지 중 워싱으로 봤을 때는 가장
독보적입니다 과하지 않는 빈티지한
느낌에 사시사철 어느 옷에나 잘
어울리는 색감인 이제라 정말 매일같이
입고 있습니다 연속해서 같이 보여
드리는 제품은 타이가 타카시의 506
더블브레스티드 가디건입니다 이건 제가
가장 최근에 구매한 타가 타카시의
제품이자 동시에 가장 오래된 것이기도
한데요 제가 블로그에 타이가 타카시를
워낙 많이 올리니까 이웃 한 분이
팝업 소식을 제게 전해 주셨었습니다
바로 펜스 댄스에서 9월에 열린
팝업이 저 혼자 공인하기 이브랜드
덕후인지라 안갈 수가 없어서 회사
선배들을 끌고 갔습니다 서울 수과
마찬가지로 팝업 때도 다도 세션이
있었는데요 제가 차 전문가는 아니지만
교토의 티 마스터 분이 기물에 담아서
정성들여 내린 차에서 그런지 처음
느끼는 진한
맛이었습니다 아무튼 차를 마시고 팝업
공간에 내려가니까 옷들이 쫙 걸려
있었어요 사실 저는 이사 FW
제품들은 화면으로 실제로든 몇 차례
봐서 내심 좀 특별한 걸 보고
싶었습니다 그런데 행거 한켠에 옛날
아카이브 피스 들 걸려 있는 거예요
그중에이 가원이 눈에 들어왔죠 제가
입고 또 고민하고 있으니까 직원분이
방금 한 분이 입어보고는 차 마시면서
구매할지 말지 결정하기로 했다고
말씀하시더라고요 그 킥을 딱 맞고
구매했습니다 근데 사실 그런 고객이
애초에 없었던 거 같기도 해요이
가디건은 몇시즌인지 잘 모르겠지만 제
추측으로는 23ss 정도일 겁니다
이옷은 19 10년대 사진 속
미국인이 보이던 가디건을 보고 영감을
받아서 만들었다고 합니다 이번 이사
FW 시즌에 소재를 좀 달리해
출시했었는데 이것도 인기가 많은지
바로 품절됐어요
독특한 건 보기와 다르게 실크
100% 이게라 실크라고 하는데
후가공을 거치지 않은 실크에 좀
거칠면서도 역설적이지만 부드러운
독특한
재질입니다이 앞서의 더블 브레스티드
굉장히 독특하면서 또 입어 보면
의외로 과하지 않아요 오히려 과한 건
기장인데이 기장이 너무
짧습니다 그래도 어디서 볼 수 없는
디자인이고 하이웨이스트라 입으면 또
괜찮아서 잘 입고
있습니다 이렇게 제가 나름 탐구하고
있는 브랜드 중 하나를 소개해
봤는데요 뭘 다뤄볼까 정리해 보니까
제 마음에 방이 꽤 많더라고요 차차
소개해 보겠습니다 오늘 제 얘기는
여기까지입니다
감사합니다
[음악]